Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is 2192.
David P Here is a question about trans youth
and surgery, puberty, blockers, etc., etc.
and it's targeted at me based on something
a viewer thinks I was, I guess, deliberately
doing the other day.
Take a listen.
Speaker 3: David.
I just watch.
Covering the Santos Christ debate when it
got to the part about.
Transitioning transgender kids.
Yep.
I noticed you were pretty quiet.
Where are you on?
Kids under 18.
And, you know, teenagers. 13, 13, 14, 15.
Taking puberty blockers and taking other transitioning
hormones and in some cases, you know, medical
search surgery.
That does it.
Yeah.
Like taking out the breast genitals.
And can you support it as gender affirming
care or do you think that if you're under
a certain age that should not be should not
be given to kids?
Speaker 1: Okay.
So, listen, I was not being deliberately quiet
for any particular reason.
My view on this issue of trans youth, puberty,
blockers, gender affirming surgery, trans
teens, 5 to 7 year olds versus 12 to 14, etc..
My view is there are so many different situations
that need to be dealt with differently, and
I am not an expert in that.
And so I know that it has become really in
for every podcast host and streamer and whatever
to take hard and fast positions on every aspect
of this.
If and when.
Puberty blockers.
Okay.
And what about the surgery and then claims
about, oh, hospitals are trying to convince
people to transition and all of this stuff
that's not backed by any actual kind of evidence
that it's taking place.
My view on this is what I currently believe
the overall position of experts, medical experts
to be not religious clergy, not Republican
or Democratic politicians.
And that is as follows You need a multi-pronged
approach when it comes to.
Trans youth, people under 18.
There are medical aspects to this.
There are social aspects to this.
There are educational aspects to this.
There are mental health aspects to this.
There are policy related questions that have
to be answered.
I don't pretend to have all the answers, and
I believe that a lot of the specific.
Elements of this are still being studied.
What I can tell you for sure is that we're
not going to get to the best outcome for the
trans youth by allowing Republicans to set
the terms of the debate, to ban all sorts
of things again, as if they know better than
doctors which were familiar with them when
it comes to abortion and on and on and on.
Now, I will also say the left should not dismiss
parts of the conversation that they don't
like.
I'm going to give you an example here.
Okay.
Here's an example of something that I've seen
some on the left dismiss.
It should be explored whether.
When a 15 year old says, I believe that I
am in the wrong body when it comes to sex.
I was born biologically male, but I feel that
I am a woman.
It should not be dismissed.
That may be that is a reflection of what is
happening in society for someone who is struggling
with something.
But it may not necessarily be that they were
born into the wrong body.
And what I mean by that is.
It should it should be explored whether there
are deeper components to what is going on.
And because of what is taking more attention
in the media right now, some folks are being
drawn to that.
Now, I know some of you will say, David, are
you saying there shouldn't be gender affirming?
No, no, no.
There should be absolutely everything.
But it should also be a conversation that
is being had.
And by the way, it is hard when people want
to transition.
There are conversations with mental health
professionals.
The right likes to pretend.
Someone says after 15 years of living as a
boy, they say, I'm a girl and two days later
they're having surgery.
That's not happening.
But the point here is.
All aspects of this should be considered.
We have a fantastic bonus show for you today.
We are going to talk about the supposed trend
of quiet quitting.
Quiet quitting.
I have a lot to say about this and I've read
quite a bit about it.
Many of you have e-mailed me saying, David,
you should discuss this.
We will today.
The world's dirtiest man has died in Iran
at age 94.
What does that mean, the world's dirtiest
man, I will tell you.
And the Nazi holding a Kanye is right sign
on the 405 freeway in California has been
identified and the situation is very quickly
getting very, very ugly.
I want you to sign up for a membership at
join Pacman dot com and then you will get
instant access to the bonus show.
Speaker 2: Thank your lucky stars every day.
You're not Dave Packman.
Speaker 1: Well, you don't have to be me.
You can just listen to the bonus show and
that's good enough.
Join Packman dot com is the place to sign
up.
You can use the coupon code big voting 22
to get a sizable discount and I look very
much forward to seeing you guys.